Hello, we’re glad you’ve joined us for this live webinar,
“Easy Automation Solutions.
Better Results.”
I’m Judy O’Rourke of LabRoots
and I’ll be moderating this session.
Today’s educational web seminar
is presented by LabRoots,
the leading scientific
social networking website
and provider
of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration
and learning.
It’s brought to you
by Beckman Coulter Life Sciences.
This webinar is actually
the first presentation
in a three-part series
on laboratory automation solutions
for smaller labs and those
less familiar with automation
who are interested
in standardizing workflows
and savings costs through
improved efficiency and results.
This year
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences
is celebrating
30 years in automation
as they continue to provide
liquid handling solutions
to help accelerate reliable results
that drive scientific discovery.
Beckman offers a full range
of flexible and scalable
Biomek automated workstations
in integrated systems
to automate genomic, cellular,
protein, and other work flows
in a wide variety of research areas
including agriculture,
cancer and infectious diseases,
cardiovascular, forensics,
and neurodegenerative disorders.
For genomic applications,
Biomek automated workstations
are complemented by a growing
portfolio of nucleic acid extraction
and purification kits
built on the company’s patented
solid phase
reversible immobilization (SPRI)
magnetic bead technology.
Let’s get started.
This webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits.
Please click on the CE button
at the bottom left corner
and follow the process
to receive your credit.
You can post questions
to the speakers
during the presentation
while they’re fresh in your mind.
To do so,
simply type in the Q&A box
which will open when you click
the green Q&A button
at the lower left
of the presentation window.
Questions will be answered
after the presentation.
To enlarge the slide window,
click on the screen icon
in the lower right hand corner
of the slide window.
If you experience
technical problems
seeing or
hearing the presentation
just click on the support button
found at the top right
of the presentation window
or report your problem
by clicking on the green
Q&A button at lower left.
I now present to these speakers
David Horvath, MS
and Zach Smith, MS
who are both
senior application scientists
for Beckman Coulter Life Sciences.
David automates
propriety and third party
next generation
sequencing chemistries.
He has a Master of Science
in Medical and Molecular Genetics
from the Indiana
University School of Medicine.
David’s career experiences span a
broad range of life science fields
including forensic DNA analysis,
medical diagnostics,
and agricultural biotech.
Zach automates propriety
and third party
next generation sequencing kits.
He has a master’s in Environmental
Science from Indiana University.
Previously, Zach worked
at the University Center
for Genomics and Bioinformatics
as a project scientist.
David will now
begin his presentation.
Thank you, Judy, and thank you
to all of our attendees.
I'm glad to have you
with us this morning,
or, I guess evening
depending on where you’re at.
As Judy mentioned, this is part 1
of a three part webinar series.
So today we’ll be talking about
introducing customers
to automating NGS workflows.
We’ll continue in June
with the second part
of DNA and RNA
sequencing sample prep
and then go into a little more
detail on specific methods
ranging from simple to complex.
And the third part of the series
is entitled “Mission Possible:
Automating NGS Sample Prep
for Challenging Samples
and Niche Applications.”
So we’ll be discussing
some of the applications
that are becoming available
for niche markets
and how we address challenges
and manual processing
for those chemistries.
Okay, to begin
we want to talk about
what a "typical" NGS workflow is.
"Typical” is in quotes
for a reason
because there really isn’t
a typical NGS workflow.
In general though
it follows this workflow
that we have on the slide.
You start with cDNA synthesis
for RNA seek applications
and then continuing from there
you have your traditional
Library Construction desk
which will include end repair,
A-tailing, ligation of the adaptors
and subsequent cleanups
after each of those steps.
PCR Enrichment
is optional for certain workflows
and depending on the workflow
Target Capture is also an optional
part of an NGS workflow.
Following the traditional
library prep construction
you will continue on
to do Library QC Quantization
and Sequencing Preparation
and the actual
Sequencing run itself.
So although most NGS workflows
follow this consistent path,
the specific workflow
can vary greatly for each application.
They can range from single day,
short and simple protocols,
to multi-day,
highly complex protocols.
Even though
the workflows can vary greatly
they all share common elements,
such as reagent and enzyme transfers,
sample transfers,
bead-based sample cleanup,
and/or size selection,
as well as thermal cycling
and incubation reactions.
So we focus on the modularity
of those common elements
and optimize those and then
construct them in different ways
to basically assemble the workflows
for each individual application.
Here we have some workflow examples
of a simple NGS workflow
for the Rubicon Genomics
ThruPlex® Plasma-seq chemistry.
The protocol takes approximately
3.5 hours to complete.
It’s performed in a single plate
for all the reactions
and there is a limited number
of start and stop points.
So it’s a relatively simple
manual process
and also
a relatively simple application
on the automation as well.
The first column here, that’s
basically your Library Construction
and the second column
is an optional cleanup
following
your Library Construction.
The next example gets into more,
I guess, the “typical” workflow
as far as complexity is concerned.
And this example is for the Illumina
TruSeq Nano DNA chemistry.
It’s approximately a 1-day protocol.
It involves multiple reactions
and cleanup plates
and has multiple
start and stop points.
And if you continue on
to a difficult
or highly complex method example
this is an example of the Illumina
TruSeq RNA Access method
which is approximately
a 3-day protocol.
It includes
Target Capture following
Library Construction
or Adaptor Ligation.
And it has an increasingly larger
number of labware consumables
due to the overall length
of the process
and it’s highly complex
with numerous start and stop points.
So again, all of these workflows
follow a series of reaction setups,
incubations, cleanups, etc.
that’s just
the length of the application
and the complexity of how
those steps are pieced together
to create the overall workflow.
So if you’re already processing
NGS samples by hand
you know the challenges
of the NGS workflow.
So some of those challenges
are significant amount
of manual pipetting steps.
So with a significant
amount of pipetting,
you have higher variability,
especially with cleanups
such as adaptor cleanups
or your final sample yields.
Often it requires
skilled pipetting.
So what I mean by that
is transferring of viscous liquids,
in-well tip mixing, or preventing
magnetic bead carryover
while transferring
to supernatant off of a plate.
Manual pipetting steps
can also contribute
to user fatigue and injury.
Manual processing
is highly error prone.
Some examples would be sample
and/or index transfer mix-ups,
sample normalization errors,
Master Mix recipe calculation errors,
and pipette volume setting errors.
So basically setting
your pipette to the wrong volume
affecting reaction chemistry,
bead ratios, etc. that are important
for cleanup or size selection.
In addition manual processing
provides limited throughput
and reduced data generation.
Small labs,
or any labs for that matter,
are always limited
in personnel resources –
how many people
you have to get the work done,
whether you have a small
or large amount of work,
people always
are the limiting factor
in how much you can get done.
Often there is more effort spent
on routine sample processing
versus
more value adding data analysis.
So automation
can minimize or eliminate
all of these challenges.
So with that being said,
Beckman Coulter would like to think
that every lab would want to automate
but we hear from customers
they’re not ready to automate.
And here
are several reasons that they give
as to why they’re not ready
to make that jump
from manual processing
to automated processing.
“We are too small.”
While automation reduces
the effort of routine processing
it increases productivity even
with limited personnel resources.
So it will allow your small lab
with a limited number of personnel
to be able to do more work,
more effectively.
And again, be able to focus on
the value adding data analysis work
versus routine sample processing.
Labs also say that “their
throughput is not high enough
to justify automating.”
Well, throughput is not
the only reason for automation.
The automation provides
more accurate
and reproducible sample data,
irrespective of sample numbers,
and is scalable
to match the lab’s growing needs.
Some labs feel that they “trust
their people more than machines.”
Biomek applications
are demonstrated and qualified
with data to support
robust performance
and I’ll talk
a little bit later
about how our development process
works for our applications
and the types of data that
we generate to support
those claims and
the performance of the application.
“Budget.”
Budgets are always limited whether
you’re a small lab or a large lab.
So automation can provide
significant savings
over manual processing
through reduced labor
or overtime pay,
reduced rework caused by human error,
and reduced consumable usage via
efficient labware and tip handling.
So encourage labs
to look at the big picture
of how automation
can fit into their workflow
and provide an overall cost savings as
compared to manual processing.
And lastly,
“We don’t have the expertise
to operate and maintain
laboratory automation.”
So Biomek’s offer is
full-featured and easy to use
which makes it the right solution
for either the novice
or experienced user.
For the middle portion
of the presentation
we’re going to talk about
what Beckman Coulter does
to develop an application.
So we’re going to start
with market research
followed by building
collaborative partnerships,
scoping the requirements
and features of the application,
and then begin
a development process
where we develop
and optimize a method
and test the method
with real reagents and generate data,
and then produce content
such as tech notes,
application notes, posters,
webinars such as this
(which go through an internal
and external review process).
That’s followed by
installations of the applications
at the customer sites
and then post-installation support.
So I’ll go over some details
on each of those parts
of our development process.
To start with
we have market research.
We’re looking out into the field
to see
what applications are in demand
and we gather that feedback
from various places
whether that’s
trade shows, customers,
publications,
journal articles, etc.
to see what people
are doing in their research.
And we utilize that
to set a queue up to prioritize
which applications we are going to
focus on developing.
When we select
the application to develop
we want to build
collaborative partnerships
with the chemistry vendors
and key research institutions.
So there is great partnerships.
We work to ensure that
the chemistry is being automated
in the manner in which it was
intended to be run manually,
so working with
the chemistry vendors to ensure
that the data quality
comes out automated
the same as it does manually,
if not better.
And we partner with key
research institutions – customers
who are either using
this chemistry already by hand
or have an interest in automating
this chemistry in their lab.
And we use that
as a real world case example
for processing these samples
in a customer’s lab.
So we generate data together
and ensure
that through that partnership
we have a robust
and reliable solution
to go off
to our broader customer base.
So as those collaborations are made,
the next step is to scope out
the requirements and features
for the particular application.
The goal is to develop
a “Template” method
that can be
readily deployed to customers.
A “Template” method
is going to be a method
that covers the majority
of options and workflows
that we expect to see
out in the field
but still be flexible enough
to offer configuration
for user-specific needs
once it gets out into the field.
We focus on things
such as throughput, capacity,
walk-away time...
We consider various accessories
and integrated devices
that are required
to perform
the various workflow steps.
Workflow options such as
sample number, safe stop points,
any type of manual interactions
for flow cycle that might be needed –
all those are considered
while scoping out the method
as well as the
instrument platform selection.
So I’ll talk about
our instrument platforms.
We have multiple configurations
which provide
flexible throughput and capability
to handle any NGS workflow.
The Biomek 4000 is
our introductory benchtop model.
It is sized just right for low
to medium throughput labs.
Typically we develop applications
anywhere from 1 to 24 samples
on this instrument.
While it can handle
greater numbers of samples,
it’s usually limited to that number
so that walk-away capability
and efficiency
is still realized on that platform.
It has a pod that has
interchangeable pipetting tools
so there are single tools
and 8 channel pipetting heads.
It also has
interchangeable grippers
so you can have the ability
to move labware on the deck
and not have them
be fixed in one spot.
The deck layout below
is the typical example
of our NGS setup
for the Biomek 4000.
It includes an orbital shaker
and static Peltier device
for keeping reagents chilled.
The next platform is our Biomek NXP
and that is going to be
our mid-sized unit.
It’s capable of medium
to high throughput workflows
up to 96 samples.
It has various pod options.
It’s a single pod which can be
either a Span-8 or a multichannel pod –
the multichannel having options
for either 96 or 384 well head.
It also has the capability
of enhanced
multi-selective tip pipetting,
which is a multichannel head
that has the capability to pipette
single rows, single columns,
or even individual wells.
So it provides some flexibility
of a Span system
while also providing the efficiency
of a multichannel head.
There are approximately
16 deck positions
in a highly customizable deck
allowing an increase
in capacity over the Biomek 4000.
And again, an example
of our typical NGS deck setup below –
with a static Peltier
in the back left corner,
there’s an orbital shaker
in the back middle,
trash chute on the right,
and the two positions
on the far left
are stacking positions.
That increases capacity
for additional tip storage
or plate storage.
And lastly
we move into our Biomek FXP
which is our largest platform.
It’s a fitting system for high
throughput or complex workflows
up to 96 samples or more.
I should stress that
the amount of throughput
you have, or size of your lab,
doesn’t necessarily
dictate the size of the instrument
that would be right for you.
If the workflow requirements
for your particular application
require a lot of cleanups
and a lot of enzyme transfers
then having a dual pod system,
regardless of throughput
or total capacity,
is still beneficial to your lab.
So the Biomek FXP can be configured
with a combination of two pods
and multichannel,
96 or 384 well head
as well as the Span-8 pod.
You can have two multichannels,
a multichannel and a Span –
any option of those.
And the deck is highly configurable.
It offers a larger deck
than the NX or the Biomek 4000
with approximately
20 deck positions.
The example NGS deck layout
that we have below
includes the integrated T-Robot
which is our integrated
thermal cycler on the left.
There is wash station
in the back row on the left
which allows for reuse
of tips after transfers,
an orbital shaker,
and then also
a static Peltier device
to keep
reagents chilled as well.
Continuing on to scoping options
and things that are considered
when developing the method,
we have options
for labware selection,
heating and cooling,
orbital shaking and tip mixing,
and tip utilization.
So labware selection
could be tubes versus plates.
What's the right labware
for your application?
It could be based on sample number,
dead volume in the tube,
what capacity
you need for your sample...
We have options
for reagent reservoirs
whether it’s a full plate reservoir...
We have modular reservoirs
as shown
in the center picture below
which can hold
different volumes of reagents
based on the amount
needed for each application.
The right modular reservoir
is matched to the volume
to reduce dead volume.
There is a necessary
magnetic plate for bead separation
with the example picture
on the bottom left there.
And then thermal cycler lids
might be another labware option
that’s needed with integrated
thermal cycling on your deck.
There’s consideration
for tip mixing versus shaking.
Orbital shaking delivers fast,
efficient plate mixing,
it reduces tip usage,
and provides uniform results.
Whereas tip mixing
works well for larger volumes,
it prevents cross contamination
with labware that is at or near well capacity,
so if you have a well
that’s almost full, orbital shaking
isn’t the right option
for that particular mix step.
So tip mixing would be deployed
for those purposes.
And tip mixing can also
access tubes or labware
that are not compatible
with an orbital shaker deck,
like a 6x4 aluminum tube rack
that will not fit
on your orbital shaker.
Heating and cooling options.
Peltiers are easy to use.
They heat and cool.
There’s various adaptors
that can be fit
onto the surface of the Peltier
to accommodate various labwares –
so round bottom wells, flat bottom,
PCR adaptors, etc.
It’s an open position
so there’s no plate sealing,
so considerations have to be made
for higher temperatures
and evaporation.
There’s a slower ramping and
cooling speed thermal cyclers have
and it’s not ideal
for all applications
such as high temperatures,
because of evaporation issues.
Thermal cycling can be
integrated on all of our platforms –
Biomek 4000, NXP, or FXP.
And the thermal cyclers
provide a true walk-away solution
not having to interact with the method
for every incubation that you need to perform.
And if you’re familiar with them,
of the longer applications,
there’s multiple incubations
that take place
which would require
multiple user interventions
for off-deck thermal cycling.
So this allows the instrument
to move the plate automatically
through the thermal cycler
and continue the method
without any user intervention.
The plate sealing lids
prevent evaporation
and then the T-Robots are compatible
with commonly used PCR labware.
And we continue to do
development work
to integrate
additional manufacturers
of thermal cycling
components as well.
So tip selection,
choosing the tip type is important
depending on the type of reagent
you’re transferring
to the type of labware
you’re trying to access.
So our tips come
in various volume ranges
from 20 microliters
up to 1,000 microliters.
There are sterile barrier
or non-barrier options.
And we also have conductive
and non-conductive tips
which are used
for liquid level sensing.
So tube access is an important
part of the selection.
The P20 tip is shorter,
it has higher volume without
the barrier than 20 microliters
and this might be the right option
for shallow microtiter plate.
Whereas a P50 is a longer tip.
It’s more slender
and it would work more effectively
with a deep well plate.
So after the labware
and the deck layout
and all the accessories
and access devices that
are selected for the application,
we then start looking
at method workflow options.
If you’re familiar
with our methods
you’re familiar
with the user interface that we have
at the start of the run.
If you’re not familiar
with our methods
all of our methods
have a user interface.
And what the user interface does
is provides all the option settings
that are relevant
to the specific applications.
And it’s going to have things
such as options for on
or off-deck thermal cycling,
options for training modes
which allows you
to quickly run through a method
without the lengthy incubations.
That can be used for training,
or optimization
and testing in your laboratory.
It includes options
for all relevant
application-specific options.
That could be, in this case,
you have the Swift Biosciences method.
There’s sample input options
and fragment size options
as well as which part of the method
that you’re wishing to run.
So in this case PCR-Free portion
of the method was selected
with various index
adaptor transfer options.
All the options
are validated for proper selection
to ensure that correct inputs
are made by the user
and will not generate errors
upon execution of the run.
And there’s also
safe stopping points built in
to these options
to allow safe stopping points,
matching the manufacturer’s protocol
ability to safely store
your samples at break points.
Safe stopping points
for pre and post PCR –
being able to stop the method
and then transfer your samples
to a different instrument
if that happens to be the way
that your lab's
quality management system dictates.
It allows for
off-deck incubations
and safe stop points
allow for recovery
by being able to perform
portions of the method
or go back in the workflow
to a previous point
and continue from there.
And lastly, other considerations
we have on the deck
for chemistry-specific issues.
There can be multiple issues,
but some examples that we have here
are considerations
for sodium hydroxide.
So certain reactions are dependent
on the sodium hydroxide
to be prepared fresh
so we have
built-in considerations for that,
where prompts are presented to the user
at the right time in the method
to present the deck
with that particular reagent.
For ethanol we have considerations
over evaporation
and water adhesion into the ethanol.
So we want to ensure
that the depth volume
is correct for ethanol
depending on the length of the run.
Walk-away is great
but if you have ethanol
on your deck for an entire day
then we definitely
have to have considerations
for those types of reagents.
So after all those considerations
are made and scoping is set out
we begin our development
and optimization process.
So template methods are written
to follow manufacturer’s protocol
and then we hit the lab.
We have a facility
here in Indianapolis
with multiple instruments
on all of our platforms.
We use live chemistry
and the ultimate goal
is to generate data with the kits
that customers
are actually going to use.
So to start
we do thorough dry testing
and logistical movement testing.
We make sure
that the method structure is sound
that the labware
is moving where it’s supposed to be.
Pipetting is occurring
in the well at the right depth
whether that's from the bottom
or the top of the plate.
When that all checks out,
we move into like-reagent testing
and what that is, is using
ethanol or glycerol solutions
to mimic enzyme transfers.
We are the manufacturer
of our bead chemistry
that you see in all the NGS kits,
so we have the ability to test
bead dispensing with an accuracy
of the bead ratios in house
with our own chemistry.
So we use
real chemistry when possible
during the like-reagent
testing and optimization.
And then we go
into optimizing and calibrating
pipetting specific to each
application or specific transfer.
So again with bead cleanups,
size selection, volume transfers,
and ratios are critical,
same for any type of reaction setup.
The balance
of the chemistry is critical
to the optimal performance
of the application.
So each of our
pipetting techniques can be dialed in
to very accurate volume transfers
across the range of the pipette tip.
So we spend time to make sure that
that’s set up as accurately as possible
to generate
the most robust results.
Following the optimization, we move
into our live chemistry testing.
So we’ve ensured
that the method is sound,
our pipetting optimization
is up to spec,
and then we actually run real kits
with real chemistry
with real samples.
If needed, after data is generated,
we continue to do optimization
that we sometimes don't see
until we use the actual chemistry.
And we continue
to fine-tune the method
until we have
the results that we’re looking for.
So we determine those results
based on generation of quantitative
and qualitative data
such as bioanalyzer tracing,
qPCR data,
and then downstream into the
sequencing data and sequencing metrics.
So the next part of our process
is content generation and review
and I’m going to hand off
to my colleague Zach Smith
and he is going to continue
with our development process
from this point forward.
Thank you very much, David.
Thank you everyone
for sticking with us for this long.
David’s done
a pretty good job so far
and I’m hoping
to pick up where he left off.
So content generation
and review process:
that’s where we generate
the technical and application notes
to demonstrate
the method capabilities
and the robustness
of our application.
The first thing we’ll do is
we will have the chemistry vendor
go through our data, either our
QC traces from the bioanalyzer,
qPCR results,
or our sequencing metrics
and review those and make sure
their chemistry vendor
is content with the results.
As David said, we have
a facility here in Indianapolis
that is fully equipped
for this work.
We have two sequencers in house,
an aluminum MiSeq and NextSeq 500,
that we can use to generate
the sequencing data we need.
If we need more data
or we have worked
on a couple of projects
that required HiSeq data
we can certainly
work with the vendors
or we send those out
for additional data analysis.
And then we will work
the bioinformatics groups associated
with the reagent vendors
to analyze those data
and interpret them properly.
The data must meet
acceptable metrics per yield,
the sizing must be accurate
and the sequencing metrics –
such as the percent
rRNA contamination,
if you’re working with an RNA method
or the percent on target read
for a capture method –
must be consistent
with what the reagent vendor
is seeing in the manual prep.
The other thing we look for
is evidence of cross examination.
So our NGS methods are working
with all the plates, typically,
which helps feed
the workflow along
because then you’re not
having to seal and unseal plates.
But we do realize that
there’s a possibility, I mean,
this represents
a risk for cross contamination
so it’s something we’re looking for
in the sequencing data.
And it is something,
because we’re looking for it
in the sequencing data,
you can see levels
that are not detectable
on bioanalyzer
or other fragment analysis traces.
And so we feel like we really do go
one step beyond what’s typical
in proving that
our automation solutions are sound
and you can trust the data
that’s being generated.
So once that review process is done
then we will generate content
for public distribution
like this webinar that you’ve
all kindly decided to show up for.
And then we’ll move on
to application installation.
So we realized that, while we have
instrument configurations
that we generally
suggest for NGS applications,
that our customers
are working with so much more
because our liquid handlers
really are application agnostic
and they’re chemistry agnostic.
And so you might be doing
NGS applications;
you might be doing
some cellular or protein work,
and so we don’t force a customer
to buy a specific configuration
for their instrument.
So we recognize that the applications
therefore that we develop
need to be flexible in their design
and that they
can be configured properly.
During the course
of application installation
our field application specialists
will go through
and they will implement
the method on your instrument.
And they will perform a whole range
of on-site pipetting optimizations
and on-site testing, frequently
going through a logistical test
to make sure
the labware is moving properly,
that your stack offsets are correct...
And then they’ll go
through some pipetting testing
and go through a complete water run,
typically while they’re at a customer site,
so that you can verify
that pipetting is on target.
And then after
the application is installed
we have an entire group
that provides tech support
for these applications
and other groups that provide
service support for the hardware.
And then
we have another third group
that provides training
and host user group meetings
for our customers.
So the reason why we do this –
it’s not like
we’re just going to through
and air drop in
an application into your site
and expect you
to just know how to use it.
We do backstop our applications with
a very extensive group of people
that do various varieties
of support for our customers.
So, there’s some
additional software features
beyond Biomek software
that I wanted to touch on
during the course
of this presentation.
Both of which are fairly new,
Biomek Method Launcher
being the newest.
But these are software packages
that we have developed
because we feel like we can offer
an improved user experience
and better data management
and handling during the course
of the method being run.
During the course of an average day
you’ll come to your Biomek and
you’ll say, “I want to run a method.
Well, are we sure
we picked the right project
and am I working with the most
recent version of my method?”
Or usually what we find out
is, “Our normal Biomek method operator
is on vacation
and the PI wants me to run an assay
and I really need
some help with this.”
So, for those reasons
and several others –
and by the way, this is what our
standard user interface looks like.
So if you were to open up
the editor on your controller
this is what you would see.
It’s fairly straightforward to use.
As far as programming is concerned
the UI gives you
a GUI faced interface
for building methods
and building out software solutions
if you want to do that.
Alternatively, you can use
Biomek Method Launcher
to launch your application
that’s been installed already.
So Biomek Method Launcher
is a new product.
It has two components to it.
One’s the launcher interface,
which you’re seeing here,
and the other one
is Guided Labware Setup.
Those are
the two primary components here.
So the launcher allows you
to interact with your instrument
without actually
running the editor software
so you would just go in
and begin Biomek Method Launcher
and your applications would be
listed out there on the launcher
and there would be icons that
allow you to select the right one.
You can also perform
manual control on the instrument
through the launcher as well,
just by clicking down
on the manual control tab
and it'll bring up a whole
a variety of options
that you can use
to run the instrument.
Once you’ve selected your method,
say for example, you want to run
Illumina TruSight HLA version 2,
an html based user interface
would pop up
and would give you the options
you need to run the method.
How many samples
you want to process
and which components of the method
that you want to run.
We built these UIs in such a way
that they’re easy to operate
and should be fairly straightforward
for any operator to employ.
The other component
of Biomek Method Launcher
is a new step
called Guided Labware Setup.
So Guided Labware Setup
will step you through
on a plate-by-plate,
tip box-by-tip box process
to set the deck up in such
a way that it’s properly set up.
And one of the things it really
does nicely is that it will go through
and will show you a side view
of stacks of labware,
so you can see that
on the right hand side of your screen.
And for reagents
that are deployed in troughs
or you have master mixes
that you need to create –
all those setup instructions
are included
in the individual
labware descriptions.
Additionally, you can print off
the Guided Labware Setup as a PDF
and you can take those setup
instructions back to your bench
or you can go and make up
your master mixes.
The other thing
you can do with those PDFs
is those PDFs can be uploaded
to a LIM system, for example,
or copied into a lab notebook
to show the user,
“This is what I’ve done
on this particular day.”
It’s a really powerful interface
and I like it quite a lot actually.
So once you get beyond
Guided Labware Setup, then,
during the course
of the method running
this is what the Run Time Interface
would look like
for Biomek Method Launcher.
So on the left,
you’ll see the method screen
where it will go through and give
you the progress bar on the top
that will show you how long
the method is going to continue.
So this answers
the vital question of:
Can I go and get a cup of coffee?
Do I have time
to go to the bathroom?
Or is it time
to interact with the instrument?
And then it will go through
and will offer you
a series of milestones
to let you know
what process it’s working on
and how long that individual
process is going to take.
If you flip over
to the method view over here
on the right hand side
of your screen,
it will actually go through
and show you the Biomek steps
that it’s actually looking through.
And if you go
into the labware dialog
which is on the right (bottom right)
of each of those screens
you can actually click
and view the volumes
on every individual piece of labware
as the method is progressing.
So you can monitor
its running in real time.
Oh yes, data handling.
Automation methods
can generate a large number of data
that will need to be tracked.
And just one well,
for example, of this one plate
we could track
what the sample ID is,
what the project ID is,
what the PI is we’re working for
on this particular project,
what species it is, the name
of the technician running the assay,
concentrations, volumes,
the list goes on and on.
And the issue gets exponentially
worse the more plates you process.
It leads to a lot of data
that needs to be handled.
And of course it’s not just from...
This data is piling up
during the course
of numerous applications.
So if you’re starting off
with NGS samples, either DNA or RNA,
you’ll want to know where
those samples were sectioned from,
any data that’s associated with them,
including species or the volume
or the concentration,
or maybe you’ll have to
quantify them yourself
when you get them in.
So one of the things you can do
is you can merge the detector data
and then track the data
and sample ID to the dilution plate
as you quantify
and normalize the DNA.
Then there’s a matter
of doing your NGS library prep
and so at that point,
you’ll want to track
what samples
are associated with what indices
so that you can do
multiplex samples later.
And then you’ll want to export
some of that data into
the Illumina Experiment Manager
for your sample sheet.
And then also extend
that data to a LIM system
if your lab has one
for a downstream analysis.
So DART 2.0, stands for
Data Acquisition and Reporting Tool.
It is a software package
that works with Biomek and SQL
to generate a repository that will
track all of that information
on a per plate basis.
So it can take reader data
it will take data from data sets
that are generated
as part of a normal operation
from Biomek software.
And it can report them out
in other devices, a LIM system,
any web-enabled device
that will allow you to monitor
the run in real time,
or other terminals
inside or outside the lab
if you have that configured right.
There are several ways
you can access the data with DART.
So you can have the DART software
create labware reports
that will automatically just
export into, say, Excel sheets
and then the report contains
an embedded link to the database
so you can just click refresh
on your Excel sheet
and then it will
automatically repopulate that sheet
with the fresh data
from the report
if you’d ran
another assay for example.
So that’s really convenient.
The other thing you can do
is you can monitor runs in real time
using the web interface.
So DART will report out
that the method is running,
how long it’s been running...
You can query
all the various sorts of labware
and find out what’s been done
and who has been doing the run.
And you can use it
to generate all kinds of reports.
So on the top left we’ve got
what the query builder looks like
and you can basically,
if you’re building a report out,
it’s just a matter of clicking
which fields
you want to include in the report.
And so above, for example,
I’ve got an illustration
where you’re using DART
to report data out
to the Illumina Experiment Manager
for sample sheet generation
including the sample
and which I5 and I7 indices
have been associated
with which library.
And on the left on the bottom there
we have the Library
Normalization Report from DART 2.0
where we’re going to be showing
what the starting concentration was,
how much volume was moved,
and what the normalization
concentration was afterwards.
So it allows you a variety of ways
of getting access
to your data and storing it.
So finally I wanted to just go
over some of our application cards.
So we’ve got a website
with a link you can see above
info.beckmancoulter.com/NGS.
And there you’ll find our current
NGS library preparation method card.
So this method card will detail
what methods we’ve developed
and what applications
we’ve developed on which platforms.
This list is continually growing
and we’re
actively adding content to it
on what seems
like a daily basis these days.
So I would strongly
encourage any and all of you
to go ahead and zip over to
this website for more information.
So finally,
I just wanted to invite anyone
to send us questions
via the Q&A tab.
Thank you for attending.
It’s been a pleasure
speaking with you.
Thank you David and Zach
for your presentations.
A quick reminder for our audience
on how to submit questions:
Simply type them in the Q&A box
by clicking on the green Q&A button
on the lower left
of the presentation window.
David and Zach will answer
as many questions as time permits.
And the first question is
for the Biomeks
capable of the 384 format,
is there a 384 well head?
Or are you pipetting four times
with the 96 well head?
And further, can the 96 head
pipette individual volume?
Okay. I can answer that question.
This is David.
The answer is yes,
the Biomeks do have options
for either a 96 or a 384 well head.
As far as the second part
of the question,
the heads cannot
pipette individual volumes
as a 96 or 384 well transfer.
However, we do have the enhanced
elected tip pipetting heads
which are capable
of doing individual row,
column,
or individual well pipetting.
So if you did have a 96
or 384 well labware format
that required different volumes
in different wells
you could use
the enhanced selective tip feature
to either deliver
or aspirate off different volumes
from different wells
within that 96 or 384 well labware.
Okay. How long does it take
to implement an existing method
with no modifications
versus one with modifications?
Yeah. I can take that.
So typically what we found
when we installed method
is that usually
there will have to be
some sort of modification
made to it when it’s deployed.
So we will have a customer
who wants to change
which PCR plate
is being used, for example,
or they’ll have
some other requirements.
Say, for example,
in the case of labs that are
working in a clinical environment,
they don’t want to reuse tips
so we will have to provide
a reconfiguration for that.
If you had no modifications to make
it’s literally a matter
of importing the method
into your Biomek Controller
which takes all of about 30 seconds
and then mapping it
on to the customer deck
which again
does not take very much time.
And then we will go
through the process
of validating the pipetting
and doing the water test run.
And that depends largely
on how complex the protocol is.
So for TruSeq PCR-Free
with no modifications
it would be approximately
two days with no changes.
But it might be more than that,
assuming that we needed
to make some modifications.
Can any of the Biomeks process
any kind of genomics kits?
Yes, our automation
is chemistry agnostic
so we can provide
automation solutions for Illumina,
New England Bio Labs,
Rubicon, Swift...
other vendors that may
or may not be more boutique.
So we also have a variety
of extraction chemistries
that we sell ourselves
including FormaPure, DNAdvance,
and RNAdvance
and we can certainly get you
more information on those
if you’re interested.
How do I get support
for developing methods
not on your list?
Do I need to wait
until your team provides them?
I can take this one.
So we do have
a pretty exhaustive list
of applications
that are demonstrated or qualified.
But if you happen
to have a requirement
for an application
that’s not on the list,
then we do have a field team
that covers the US, globally actually,
to be able to handle
those specific needs
and develop methods
out in the field.
So a lot of times the voice of customer
and the market research
that I talked about earlier
actually comes from our field team.
So they’re out working
with the customers every day
and method application development
could actually start in the field
and it does quite often.
So they will develop those methods
then route them
through the internal group
and allow us to kind of
add additional features,
the UI options, etc.
that will then be able
to be utilized by many labs.
And in addition,
the collaborative support
that we have for the in house
development of applications
extends out to methods
that were developed in the field.
So if a customer wants
a particular vendor’s chemistry,
field application scientist,
develops it, then those vendors
do partner and work closely with us
to ensure that customers’ results
are optimized
for field developed methods as well.
How often
do you add methods to your menu?
It seems like weekly.
Just in the last few weeks,
we’ve added five applications
to the repository that we
sourced the method card from.
So our development process
is continuous
and it’s mostly based
on market demand.
So we have a focus on providing
more solutions for small labs now
so you’ll see an increase
in the cadence of Biomek 4000
and Biomek NXP methods.
What’s the pipetting
volume range for your system?
I can handle that one too.
So for the Biomek 4000
we can pipette anywhere
from 1 to 1,000 microliters
depending on the tip that’s loaded
and the head that’s used
for a 1 microliter transfer,
for a P20 tip,
the precision
or the inaccuracy is 5 percent.
For a P1000 tip,
for a 1,000 microliter transfer,
it’s 2 percent inaccuracy.
For our Span-8 systems,
we can pipette accurately
down to half a microliter
with an accuracy
of approximately 5 percent.
We do actually have
an application note around that
but we can certainly get the people
if they’re interested
in seeing some of the data.
Is there any project to get
low retention tips from Beckman?
I can answer that.
Basically, the plastic
that we use is always,
I guess they call it,
virgin polystyrene.
It’s not recycled.
And the tips are all essentially
spec’ed out to be low retention.
And a lot of the pipetting
optimization also increases
the recovery from samples
and liquids within the tips
so for viscous liquid,
slower pipetting helps deliver
controlled delivery
of the viscous liquid
ensures optimal recovery.
But again, all of our tips
are considered to be low retention.
Can you link
the sample tracking to Lab Guru?
That’s a good question.
I’m looking up Lab Guru now.
I don’t see why not
as long as Lab Guru is able
to handle CSV formatted files
that the sample tracking
could generate.
I would need to know
specifically more
about that particular application
before I could offer you
a solid yes or no.
Okay. Give us a moment
to see additional questions.
Hang on one second.
So I would like to once again
thank David Horvath
and Zach Smith
for their presentations.
Do you have any final comments
for us today?
Just thank you everyone
for attending;
it’s been a pleasure
speaking with you.
If you have
any further questions or comments
please get in touch with us.
We’d be happy to hear from you.
And we’d love to have you
join us again
on part two and part three
of our webinar series.
Again, those are titled “DNA and RNA
Sequencing Sample Prep” for part 2
that will take place on Thursday,
June 23rd, same time.
And part 3
is entitled “Mission Possible:
Automating NGS Sample Prep
for Challenging Samples
and Niche Applications.”
And that will take place
on Thursday, July 28th
at the same time,
8 o’clock am Pacific and 11 Eastern.
I’d like to thank the audience
for joining us today
and for their interesting questions.
We’d also like to thank our sponsors
Beckman Cultural Life Sciences
for underwriting
today’s educational webcast.
As a reminder
in case some of you missed
what the speakers just told you
the webinar is the first part
of a three-part series.
So save the dates
for the upcoming presentation
part 2, “DNA and RNA
Sequencing Sample Prep
Automating Simple to Complex Methods”
will be presented on June 23rd.
And part 3, “Mission Possible:
Automating NGS Sample Prep
for Challenging Samples
and Niche Applications”
will be presented on July 28th.
Registration is now open
for both of these webinars
so feel free to visit
the LabRoots website
to confirm your attendance today.
This webinar has been approved
for continuing education credits.
Please click on the CE button
on the bottom left corner
and follow the process
to receive your credit.
This webcast can be viewed on demand
through November 19th, 2016.
LabRoots will alert you via email
when it’s available for replay.
We encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues
who may have missed
today’s live event.
Until next time, goodbye.